[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en Francia 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días estos son
los titulares comenzamos esta edición
con las tensiones entre la junta militar
al mando en guineakora cree y la
comunidad económica de Estados de África
occidental las ideal este organismo
anunció sanciones progresivas contra los
militares así pretende presionarlos para
forzar una transición a un poder civil
democrático hablamos también de la
libertad de prensa que está cada vez más
amenazada en Marruecos analizamos el
caso de Omar Rally un periodista
condenado en marzo a seis años de cárcel
después de su detención el caso que
investigaba fue llevado a cabo por
periodistas de forbidden Stories tenemos
informe Y por último vamos a Costa de
Marfil donde un pionero de la tecnología
creó el primer teléfono en se hace
totalmente con la voz y que funciona en
16 idiomas locales es un éxito entre los
usuarios que no saben leer ni escribir
empezamos con la reunión extraordinaria
de la comunidad económica de Estados de
África occidental a la seda celebrada en
Nueva York al margen de la asamblea
general de la ONU los líderes de África
occidental anunciaron sanciones y un
ultimátum de un mes a la junta militar
que gobierna en Guinea con actriz para
obligarla a reducir el plazo de la
transición a la democracia los militares
llegaron al poder en septiembre de 2021
e informaron en abril de 2022 que el
período de transición sería de tres años
antes de dar paso a un gobierno civil
veamos las principales sanciones
decretadas por las ideal a algunos
miembros de la junta se les prohibiera
viajar y sus bienes serán congelados la
organización suspenderá todas las ayudas
y transacciones financieras a favor de
Guinea por parte de sus instituciones
financieras y por último los estados
miembros de la serie ao retirarán a sus
Embajadores acreditados en el país
unas horas antes de la Cumbre de la seda
o el actual presidente de esta
organización humanos
calificó de inaceptable el calendario de
transición decidido por la junta
escuchemos sus respuestas a las
preguntas de los periodistas Marc
perelman y Christopher de Francia 24 y
radio France internacional
y no negociable
no es negociable es incondicional no
podemos aceptar esto
el líder de la junta intercambian con él
o también se han roto Los puentes no no
no no no no no no
no he estado allí como dije cuando asumí
el cargo he estado en dos países burkina
faso y Guinea conakry
y aquí viene con actriz
hablamos y llegamos al consenso de que
no podemos superar los 24 meses esto no
es negociable para la cdao por la serie
antes del anuncio de las sanciones estos
comentarios habían provocado la ira de
los militares guineanos que los
calificaron de vergonzosos escuchemos al
Coronel amar acabará portavoz de la
junta
no se trata de un espectáculo de
marionetas ni un reality show sino de
relaciones diplomáticas entre Estados
responsables que requieren respeto sobre
el tema de las sanciones preconcebidas
responderemos que no es una sorpresa
viniendo del presidente en balón
lamentamos sus comentarios de arrogancia
contra nuestro país y una imposición a
otros jefes de estado de la cdao
el planteamiento del presidente envaló
es una demonización del régimen de
transición en Guinea esto no funcionará;
cambiamos de tema y de región nos vamos
a Marruecos en el norte de África donde
la libertad de prensa está cada vez más
amenazada según una organizaciones de
defensa de Derechos Humanos como human
right watch o amni internacional en este
sentido el caso de Omar Rally es
paradigmático condenado a seis años de
cárcel en marzo este periodista
investigaba a las expropiaciones de
tierras que comprometían a grandes
empresas y a familiares del Rey Mohamed
sexto Omar Rally no pudo terminar su
investigación pero la organización
Providence Stories cuyo objetivo es
finalizar Las investigaciones
inconclusas la ha continuado nuestra
corresponsal Sofía Catalán analiza el
caso de Omar Rally
radio cumple una condena de seis años de
cárcel por los supuestos delitos de
espionaje al estado y violación a una
excompañera de trabajo acusaciones que
el periodista ha negado en todo momento
fue detenido en junio de 2020 después de
denunciar de la mano de amnistía
internacional que las autoridades
marroquíes le habían sometido a
vigilancia mediante el dispositivo de
espionaje israelí pegasus por aquel
entonces a Omar estaba investigando la
expropiación de tierras y la corrupción
vinculada a las altas esferas del poder
en Marruecos Ya llevaba tiempo en el
punto de mira de las autoridades y
también de sus medios digitales afines y
los delitos inconexos por los que ha
sido juzgado Omar supuesto espionaje y a
la violación además han sido
investigados en un único proceso
judicial que organizaciones como
amnistía internacional
Sin fronteras consideran Injusto
denuncian a violaciones flagrantes de
las garantías procesales en el caso de
aomara radi Como por ejemplo
la limitación a de su acceso a sus
abogados también la exclusión de
testimonios clave para la defensa así
como la no admisión a de pruebas
determinantes contra la violación
también estas organizaciones han
publicado recientemente informes
demoledores sobre la libertad de prensa
aquí en Marruecos en los que condenan la
instrumentalización de los delitos
sexuales por parte del Estado dicen como
modus operandie para callar a las voces
críticas también entre los casos más
sonados de persecución Cabe destacar el
del periodista Suleimán raichuni que fue
encarcelado poco antes que amarrado y
también por supuestos delitos sexuales
que no pudieron llegar a probarse y que
el periodista asegura no haber cometido
el fallecimiento de la Reina Isabel II
fue para algunos momentos solemne pero
también una oportunidad para que muchos
países africanos especialmente las
antiguas colonias del Reino Unido
recordarán los crímenes cometidos por el
gobierno británico
por ejemplo no se olvida la Sangrienta
represión de la revuelta del Mau Mau
entre 1952 y 1956 la rebelión del Mao
Mao consistió en una insurrección de
Rebeldes kenianos contra la
administración colonial británica veamos
en esta granja vive una de las familias
más importantes de la rebelión a sus más
de 100 años mutón y matengue recuerda
vividamente la lucha por la
independencia que comenzó al principio
del reinado de la Reina Isabel segunda
Hola hola
me golpearon varios policías después de
que secuestraran a mi hija me golpearon
una de las manos con una pistola y la
pierna con un hacha aquí y aquí me
llamaron gorda y otros soldados siguió
golpeándome con una pistola
fue en 2013 cuando el gobierno británico
aceptó por primera vez indemnizar a más
de 5.000 genianos una pequeña parte de
las víctimas con 23 millones de euros
muttoni no recibió nada
el gobierno británico es muy consciente
de la situación y conoce todos los
errores que hemos sufrido tienen El
Deber de compensar a los motonic que
todavía están aquí
putón espera obtener una compensación
antes de la muerte de la reina aunque no
culpa directamente y se ve el segunda de
lo ocurrido está resentida con el
sistema colonialista que le suprimió
Daniel o quería
estaba con un hombre llamado quigano y
sus tres hijas
nos atacaron ellos fueron asesinados
como muchas otras personas por el
gobierno británico
cuando Kenia obtuvo su independencia en
1963 los británicos se fueron con los
documentos y los archivos de la época
colonial borrando las huellas de sus
crímenes no fue hasta 2011 que una
sentencia judicial hizo accesible
algunos de estos archivos
regresar todos los registros que hemos
podido conservar son bastante
inquietantes incluso repugnantes no es
algo que se pueda hacer las víctimas del
movimiento estos luchadores por la
libertad siguen guardando hasta el día
de hoy rencor al gobierno británico
la muerte de la reina ha provocado
sentimientos contrarios sobre su reinado
con recientes peticiones para que el
Reino Unido reconozca las atrocidades
cometidas por las autoridades del
imperio británico en Costa de Marfil un
teléfono diseñado y ensamblado
localmente está teniendo un gran éxito
comercial el dispositivo es totalmente
controlado por voz y opera en 16 idiomas
locales africanos este celular puede ser
utilizado por todos aquellos que no
saben escribir ni leer veamos el informe
de OMS nomenio y damiakofy
se llama Open y es un teléfono que habla
varios idiomas africanos
Cuál es mi saldo
pregunto y me da mi saldo en la lengua
baúllé este teléfono móvil fue diseñado
para que sea más fácil de usar para las
personas que no saben leer ni escribir
Cuál es mi número de teléfono
para los padres es muy importante porque
cuando les preguntas por su número de
teléfono no lo pueden decir porque
muchos no lo conocen
más clienta y comerciante es una de esas
personas que desde que empezó a utilizar
el teléfono Open no ha tenido
dificultades para su uso lo único que
tiene que hacer es pedir por vos lo que
necesita
este teléfono es bueno porque habla
muchos idiomas si Quiero llamar a mis
padres hablo en francés y me responde el
muro y en muchos idiomas así que me
gusta mucho el teléfono se fabrica en
gran Bazán una ciudad del sureste de
Costa de Marfil alenka positi el
diseñador es originario de benín Y fue
el primer empresario en crear una
plataforma de montaje de computadores en
África occidental para su nuevo teléfono
ya está pensando en grande
ondulante blanco
Más allá de las 50 Lenguas que ya
tenemos de las 16 de Costa de Marfil
queremos llegar a mil lenguas africanas
y nos complace constatar que ya hay casi
2000 hablantes de esos idiomas que se
han inscrito hoy y con los cuales ya
trabajamos Open está disponible en el
mercado marfilenio a un precio que varía
entre 45 y 91 dólares y ya está a la
venta en Benin burkina faso y en la
República democrática del Congo
fue en la cárcel que el artista
sudafricano blessing goveny cogió por
primera vez un pincel cuando dibujaba a
sus compañeros este mes el artista de 35
años presentó su obra en la fnb Art de
johannesburgo en Sudáfrica una
importante exposición de arte
contemporáneo su obra titulada Spirit of
water dancing se expuso con una serie de
sillones antiguos inspirados en el
descubrimiento en 2016 de un sillón en
Georgia en Estados Unidos tapizado con
cabello de esclavos Nos despedimos con
imágenes de esta exposición Gracias por
acompañarnos la actualidad internacional
sigue en francés 24 y Francia 24.com
[Música]